Merhabalar küçük bir teknik aksaklık
oldu orada arkada mikrofonda
Beni tanıyor musunuz
aranızdaki annem ve arkadaşlarım dışında
beni tanıyacağımızı sanmıyorum Ben kimim
size adımı yaşımı Okulu belki dünya
küçük Ailem aktarırsam beni tanımış
olacak
birini tanırken ipuçlarımı Sonlara doğru
söyleyeceğim sizlere
Dur daha
sorayım neden
buradasın konuşmamın ileriki
dakikalarında bu soruyu tekrar
sordum
Evet elimdekini görebiliyor musunuz
Bu bir kurşun kalem pek gözükmüyor
galiba
Ama burada da bir kalem var içelim
Peki benim
neden iki tane kalem ihtiyacım olabilir
buna birçok sebep sayabiliriz Kurşun
kalemin
hissiyatı mekanik kalemin inceliği
rahatlığı birçok sebep
[Müzik]
bir amaca yönelik kullanıyorum bir amaç
atıyorum çizim yapmak
iki bir soru sorayım
ikisinin orta katası kim
boyan madde kömür
Nerede eski marv duvarlarında ki
resimlerde
Peki İnsanlar neden mağaraları boyama
ihtiyacı hissetmiş olabilirler
Şu an tam olarak bilemiyoruz
bunun bir çok sebebi olabilir
yaşadıklarını aktar
mak ilk belki Günlük tutmak istemişler
var bir amaç doğrultusunda yapılmış bu
Evet konuşmalı teması amaç olacak
amaç nedir
te bulaştırmak
isteyene doğru bir tanım
ulaşılmak kelimesi
oldu olmak olarak değişiyor Çünkü amaç
bizi Yoldayken hayatta tutan şey değil
midir
burada bir doktor görseli var
Doktor olmak sizce bir amaç mıdır
çoğu velimiz öğretmenimiz için bu
olabilir fakat Doktor olmak acaba
hayallerimizi amaçlarımızı
gerçekleştirmemizi
Burada da bir gönüllü doktor var Sahra
doktorlu
yani çok uzun süreler düşünmüştüm
niye Suyun bile sorun olduğu bir bölgeye
gider
niye böyle bir fedakârın altına girer
amaç söyleyemeyeceğim ama bildiğim bir
şey var bu kadar büyük bir fedakarlığı
bir amaç doğrultusun
ekranda 3 tane dünya var
1 Dünya 2 Dünya'ya göre
küçük alt solo olarak
da duvarları da küçük İkinci Dünya
birinci Dünya'ya göre büyük
kullanılabilir alanında artmış fakat
duvar
[Müzik]
lar bir yakınlaşmaya Ne dersiniz
Küçük Prens çoğumuzun
Biz düşündüğümüzde ne yapıyorduk biz
acıktığımızda ağlıyorduk Sevgi
istiyorsak sevdiğimiz birine
sarılıyorduk
istediğimiz gibi küçük amaçlarla
yaşıyorduk başkalarının bize çizdiği
duvarlarımız olmadan Tabi buna
Annelerimizin babalarımızın her Kimisi
büyüttüyse bize yaptıkları
zorla yemek yedirmeler dahil değil
[Müzik]
peki
amacın amacı ne bu kadar fazla amaç
hakkında konuştuk mutluluk
benim için laboratuvarda sabahlayan
bilim insanında da bir seri katilde de
durum öyle mutluluk
başarı şu an Şöhret Para her şey
mutluluk için
her şeyi mutluluk için yapıyorsak
Aslında Hepimizin bir amacı yok mu Evet
Hepimizin bir amacı var fakat bazen
dizginler elimizde olmuyor
gönlünü hoş tut hoş şu durmadan dağılan
alemde Hepsi Bir nefestir Gerisi de
boştur Boş
hepimiz
bir gün dolan varsa bilemiyorum ben
Evimizde bir amaç uğruna Yaşamak yaşamış
olmalıyız
Evet amaç uğruna çalıştığınız her şey
olabilir buna burada görselleri de
verdiğim Sanat bilim spor her şey
olabilir
bunu bir örneği ile alarak iki farklı
senaryoda inceleyelim Biz temizlik
görevlisi birinci senaryoda temizlik
görevliliğimiz sadece görevini yerine
getir
ebilmek için ama temizliğine baştan
sağma yapıyor ikinci temizlik
görevlilerimizin bir amacı var
insanların hasta olmamasını sağlamak Bu
yüzden işini Elinden en iyi şekilde
gerçekleştiriyor
burada ikinci senaryoda
çalışanımızın amacı ve görevi rezonans
'a giriyor sınırlı kalmıyor
birincisi senaryoda çocuğumuz yerden
mikrop kapıyor ve
ikinci senaryoda
çalışanımız o yeri gerçekten düzgün
sildiği için hastalıkla mücadele etmek
zorunda kalmıyor Çocuğunuz
ilk başta baktığımızda küçük gelmiş
değil mi bir yeri silmek Evet ilk küçük
ama o küçük şeyden çocuğun hayatını
etkileyecek kocaman bir şeye dönüştü ne
kadar Muazzam değil mi
Evet
amacınızla birleşerek niye rezonansla
girerek bir sonraki Nobel servissiz
olmuyorsun
Uz veya dünyayı geri dönebilecek şekilde
değiştiren elini
bir ölçü
Evet bir diğer değinmek istediğim yurt
dışı öğrenci seçimleri
ülkemizden katılım sağlayanlar oluyor
buna Ama orası olarak çok az yurtdışına
20.000 Türk öğrenci varken ülkemizde 8
milyon
o yüzden
kısaca Sizin bir amaç uğruna bir şeyi
araştırmış çalışmalı
Bir örnek üzerinden gidelim Evet siz çok
güzel matematik sorusu çözüyor
olabilirsiniz fakat
ilk sayıyı nereden çıkmış
[Müzik]
kişi olmuş
veya bir teorem nasıl ortaya çıkmış
matematik gerçekten Kusursuz mu
Evet Siz matematiği çok seviyorsunuz
Peki ben nasıl katkı sağlayabilirim
bilime
matematiği
matematikte nasıl iz bırakabilirim
Burada sizi Selin Zeynep artanla
tanıştırmak istiyorum seninle bir bilim
kartı ile tanışmıştık kendisinin lise
hayatı oldukça zor ve yorucu geçmiş
kendisinin Türkiye dereceleri dünyanın
en prestijli yarışmalarından olan
uluslararası Mühendislik yarışması
isef'e katılım gibi birçok lisede
yaptığı şey var burada anlatamayacağı
kadar çok fazla
Hatta istediği Okula gitmek için 2 yıl
kalıyor neden
Çünkü ne yapmak istediğini ve amacını
bilmiyor
bu iki yıllık süreçte okuyor dinliyor
merak ediyor araştır
ıyor ve kendine oluşturuyor
hatta kendisi benim çok büyük bir uyku
sorunum vardı kendisine uykuyu nasıl
hallettiğini sorduğunda artık o kadar
fazla uyumadım ki uyku benim Konfor
alanından çıktı demişti
Peki siz dedim bu kadar fazla uğraştım
niçin de amacı içinde 2 yıl sonra ne
oldu
Selim aynı sevgiyle başvurdu Fakat bu
sefer aynı seri değildi farklı bir Selim
de başvurdum
Evet bu yolda
çalışanlar olacak
düşünelim futbol Siz futbolcu olmak
istiyorsunuz ve yeteneğinizin olduğunu
düşünüyorsunuz veya
çalışarak yeteneğinizi
geliştirebileceğinizi düşünüyorsunuz
sol tarafta herkesin daha güvenli olarak
gördüğü ve doğru olarak bildikleri yol
önünüzdeki seçenek istiyor
ya vazgeçeceksiniz ya da amacınıza
sarılacaksınız
burada bir diğer bahsetmek
istediğim
ve Makbule
kendisini insan hayatına kısaca
baktığımızda Göze çarpmak çok büyük bir
şey var NASA tarafından burs kazanıyor
[Müzik]
sanırım
Hep ders çalışsın dediği için
katılamıyor
fazla üzülmüştüm ve üzüm tüm
kendisiyle kendisi Peki bundan sonra ne
yapıyor
çalışmalarından merak ettikleri
araştırdıklarına devam sürekli
geliştirerek devam ediyor
ve Mustafa Oruçken şu an 22 yaşında bir
siyah
Evet Kanatlar uçmadıktan sonra Kanatlar
neye yarar
sizin Belli bir yetkinliğiniz
yeteneğiniz olabilir fakat siz bunu
yolda yürürken kullanmadığınızda
harcanmış bir
Botan şimdi daha eğlenceli olan kısma
geçelim sizden 3 tane kelime rica
ediyorum ve bir
amaçla burada herhangi bir şekilde
kelimeler yazmıyor
şimdi cesaret olan 3 arkadaşlar yüksek
sesle bağırarak 3 tane kelime rica
ediyorum
arkadaşlar 3 tane 2 tane kelime aldım
mutluluk ve deniz
insanı
aldım şu an kuruyorum Siz de duydunuz
insanlar denize girdiğinde mutlu
oluyorlar
çocuklar daha denizle bilmiyorlar nasıl
bir hissiyat
benim bir amacım bir hayalim var
çocuklara denize ulaştırabilmek
bakın birlikten ne güzel bir amaç lazım
değil mi
bir amaç bulmak çok zorlu bir süreç
değil
dilinde yaşadığı gibi o iki yıllık
süreçte kendini geliştirdiği gibi
bulunması gerektiğini ikna edemediğim
arkadaşlara son bir göstereceğim şey var
Ateş İnsanlığın en büyük keşfi
yabani hayvanlardan korumanız lazım
aydınlanmanız lazım besinlerinizi ateş
gibi muazzam bir keşif var
her şeyi bir kıvılcımla bir ateşle bir
amaçla başladım
görüyor musunuz
Evet bir tane arkadaş çok iyi dinlemiş
ve burada size bir ipucu paylaşacağımı
söylemiştim
insan tanırken amaçlarına ve hayallerine
bakıyorum Çünkü Hayaller Gerçekten çok
güzel der biz aslında
için hayalimizdeki kişiyiz Çünkü
hayalimize ulaşmak için çabalıyoruz
bir diğer sorum vardı
Evet
buna ben kendi cevabımı vereyim ben niye
buradayım
benim bir amacım var
şeyden herkesten Hatta dünkü benden bile
farklı olarak devam etmek
Bu amaç kulağa çok süslü gelebilir ve
imkansız gelebilir Evet
dünkü benden farklı olabiliyor muyum
gözlemlediğimizde çok fazla olmuyor Bazı
günler hiçbir şey
yapmıyormuş ama Sizce ben bir yıl önce
Beni Tan
ıyan klasik bir bakkaldan ekmek almaya
bile Korkardım Evet ben bakkaldan ekmek
almaya bile Korkardım ve şu an 450 kişi
önümde bir konuşma yapmaya çalışıyorum
Umarım başarılı olurum
[Alkış]
Evet konuşmamı küçük bir soru daha
ekleyerek size sonlandırmak istiyorum
çıkışta bir gün sonra bir ay sonra bir
yıl sonra nerede ve niçin olacaksınız
içinizdeki Ateşi
ortaya çıkaracak mısınız kıvılcımı
yakacak mısınız
ben
Muhammet rezil için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]